thank you I'm Nick Barba I'm a senior
here at school without walls school
without walls is a DC public school it's
a magnet school on the campus of George
Washington University and as you may be
able to see behind me we do indeed have
walls but the name refers to the fact
that we use the city as a classroom and
we take a lot of field trips and we do a
lot of learning outside of the school
building we make the most of our
position here in Washington DC and we're
very glad to have with us today
Congressman Bernard Sanders from Vermont
congressman Sanders is an independent
socialist he's the leader of the
Progressive Caucus of the House of
Representatives and as a progressive
school where we are very delighted to
have him so Congressman Bernard Sanders
thank you very much
why you need this no I don't need to see
I'll give it back to you I am delighted
to be with you and I'm gonna chat for a
little while then I'm gonna stop and
open it up to any questions or thoughts
that you may have and actually this
format is something that I'm very
familiar with because in the state of
Vermont this is what I do all the time
we have about 55 high schools and I've
been to almost every one of them and the
reason that I go out to high schools and
the reason that I'm delighted to be here
today
is that one of the issues that concerns
me very much is that young people your
age by and large know very little about
how government works know very little
about politics when we have national
elections in the United States some of
you may know that we have the lowest
voter turnout of any major country on
Earth we call ourselves a democracy and
yet in the last election fewer than 40
percent of the people voted and as bad
as that situation is it is worse for
young people under 25 years of age we're
talking about 20 or 25 percent of the
young people voting and that is a very
frightening development because as those
people get older the likelihood is they
will not vote and the voter turnout will
go down down and down and if ordinary
people and young people and working
people and low-income people don't vote
and don't participate in the political
system
who
do you think is going to be making the
decisions it will be made by the people
who have the money
who will make decisions that influence
the lives of your family and yourselves
and the decisions that they make in all
likelihood are not going to be in your
best interests so the first point that I
want to make this morning is if anyone
tells you that politics is crap it's
garbage don't get involved do not
believe them for a moment the decisions
being made every single day at the
nation's capital or your city government
are of enormous importance to your lives
and if you don't participate other
people will fill that vacuum so
participate learn ask the hard questions
that's issue number one let me tell you
a little bit about myself because this
this program deals with leadership
generally speaking my political profile
and who I am and where I've come from is
probably different is different than any
other member of the United States
Congress now why is that for a start in
the House of Representatives in which
there are 435 members there is one
independent and you're looking at them I
am the only independent at the House of
Representatives I was elected in 1990 as
the first person outside of the
Democratic and Republican parties in 40
years and I'm now the longest serving
independent in American history how did
I get involved in politics
how was my background different than
other people generally speaking most
people who make it to the Congress start
off in the Democratic Party or the
Republican Party and they work their way
up and they got elected to Congress
my background is somewhat different in
1971 a long time ago the United States
Senator from the state of Vermont died
in office and it was a special election
I ran and competed in that election as a
third party candidate not as a Democrat
not as a Republican I had no money and I
was affiliated with a very small
progressive third party called the
Liberty Union party 1971
and I thought I had no illusions that I
was gonna win this election but I
thought it would be important to go out
around the state and talk to people
expressing my views about the state of
the economy the Vietnam War as was then
going on and see how we could do well on
Election Day the votes came in and I
received not thirty percent of the vote
not forty percent of the vote but two
percent of the vote
so the first point that I'm gonna make
to you today is don't give up but I was
not smart enough unlike many of you I
was not very smart and I said hey I got
two percent of the vote I'm gonna try
again and in Vermont which i think is a
good thing we have elections every two
years for statewide offices and so forth
so another year came in 1972 and I said
I am gonna run for governor of the state
of Vermont having won overwhelming
support with 2% what do I have to lose
how much worse can I do well I actually
did worse I went from 2% down to 1% but
the voter turnout was larger so I got
more actual votes but my percentage went
down again being one of those people
who's too dumb to know when he's licked
you know I came back again and two years
later I ran for the United States Senate
again and instead of getting 2% of the
vote I got my total all the way up to 4%
two years later I ran for governor of
the state of Vermont and this time I
made it up to 6 percent for races and I
managed to fight my way up to 6 upset
now see some of you are smiling but what
you should know if you check your
history running is a third party
candidate actually getting six percent
of the vote is not bad it is very hard
because people in our country
traditionally they're a Democrat they're
gonna vote Republican asking them to go
outside of the two-party system with
ideas that they don't necessarily see on
television or hear on the radio reading
the newspapers every day different ideas
ain't so easy so 6% wasn't that bad but
by this time I also have to make a
living and do things like that live a
normal life so I retired from politics
and then I went about my business of as
a writer doing film scripts educational
film strips did a videotape
and so forth and so on 1981 five years
later some people in the city that I
live in Vermont is a very small state
very rural state our largest city is
called burlington vermont where i live
it has all of 40,000 people it's by far
the largest city in the state of vermont
but compared to cities all over america
very small anyhow some people came up to
me and they said you know we have a
democratic machine in the city of
burlington we have a mayor who has
served i think it was six terms they're
not really representing the people that
are dealing with issues like affordable
housing creating a people oriented
waterfront our city is a beautiful city
located on Lake Champlain a lot of
problems in our city Bernie why don't
you run for mayor of Burlington and I
was reluctant to do it but enough people
said do it so we did it we put together
an interesting coalition coalition
politics we put together some of the
unions and I'm a strong believer in
trade unionism the workers in the city
government who aren't happy with what
was going on we put together
neighborhood organizations that
represented working people and
lower-income people we put together
people who are concerned about the
environment especially what was going on
in our waterfront
and lo and behold on Election Day was a
three-way race there was another
gentleman in the race I ended up late in
the night winning that election in 1981
for mayor Burlington by a landslide of
14 votes they did a recount my lead went
from 14 down to 10 but everybody's
shocked in the state of Vermont I became
the mayor of Burlington now when I
walked in the door is mayor Burlington I
had a little bit of a problem because
there were 13 people on the City Council
two of them had come in as supporters of
mine but the rest were all Republicans
and Democrats mostly Democrats they were
not very happy with the fact that a new
guy not a Democrat a Republican was
suddenly the mayor of a city who had a
different agenda so the very first
formal action that the City Council took
was to fire my secretary got it the one
person that I had in my staff they fired
and they forced me to work for many many
months
with they wouldn't let me hire my own
administration it was a very very bitter
and confrontational period got me very
angry
and we have half of the City Council
comes up every year so a year later in
1982 along with a number of other people
in the city we put together another
coalition to run for City Council people
who were supporting my initiatives as
mayor and we won three seats plus the
two that we had which was five seats
which gave me veto power would suddenly
change the balance of power on the City
Council and the Democrats and
Republicans suddenly had to deal with
the mayor and a year later the Democrats
and Republicans ran against me one two
years later
Democrat Republican running against me
one two years later than well they
combine parties but we want anyhow and
we took on all of the special interest
in the city all of the moneyed interests
all of the powers that be and one of the
exciting things about what I did as
mayor was that we came close to doubling
the voter turnout why did we do how did
that happen because a lot of working
people lower-income people have been
ignored for years
saw that there was a mayor standing up
fighting the fights for them fighting
for a fairer tax system to break our
dependency on the regressive property
tax fighting for a people-oriented
waterfront where people can enjoy the
waterfront rather than just expensive
condominiums fighting for affordable
housing fighting for youth programs the
woman who was the head of our youth
office eventually became my wife and did
a great job in establishing after-school
centers little league programs we
started we were concerned as every
sensible person is now what happens to
young people if they don't have a place
to do constructive activity so we
slaughtered a teen center in the City of
Burlington where kids can come and
listen to their loud terrible music but
do it on their own and we prefer that
than drugs and in cigarettes and so
forth so we made sweeping changes all
over the city
in 1986 I ran for governor of the state
well this time while I was mayor I did
better I got 14% of the vote
still far from winning 1988 I ran for
the Congress
and in a strange three-way race
the guy who won was a Republican he got
34% of vote
I got 31% the Democrat got 19% as slowly
as you can see moving up the ladder two
years later in 1990 I ran against the
same fellow again and won by a whole lot
got 56% of the vote I think he got 40%
and I've been reelected ever since okay
in Congress what I try to do is to do
what too few people I think do and that
is stand with working people in the
middle class and lower-income people to
make sure that we create an economy that
works for everybody rather than just the
very rich and what goes on in our
country today and I don't know if they
tell you it in your textbooks or what
kind of teachers you have but a lot of
what really goes on is not reported in
the books the reality is that in
Congress hundreds of millions of dollars
flood into the political coffers of both
political parties the Republicans much
more than the Democrats I started in
1990 a group called the progressive
caucus which now has some 55 members it
is the most integrated caucus
rural-urban black white Hispanic women
men and our function is to represent
working families to make sure that all
of our people in this country can have a
decent standard of living but the most
important reality about politics which
has not talked about enough is the power
of money go to any of the websites that
are out there that deal with campaign
finance reform and what you will find is
that the white house members of Congress
members of the Senate receive huge
amounts the money from wealthy people
big money people every once in a while
you'll see the president go to a little
fundraising dinner in Washington and any
of you can go to that fundraising dinner
- the only problem is you know you have
to pay to get into the room about
$25,000 a plate it's a very but I want
to tell you it's a very good dinner and
you can get an extra cup of coffee
service is very good so for me at
$25,000 you can go to dinner with the
president now why do people pay the
$25,000 and that's just a small part of
what they pay
because they understand when they put
that money in their needs get taken care
of and not the needs of your families so
instead of talking about raising the
minimum wage so that everybody in our
country could have a living wage we
don't talk about that in the Congress
because the people with the money are
not interested in raising the minimum
wage what do they want well they have
millionaires and they're billionaires
that's not enough they need a tax break
so the president's tax proposal will
give the average millionaire a ninety
thousand dollar tax break the richest 1%
will get one-third of all of the tax
breaks the same amount the richest 1/10
of 1% will get the same amount in tax
breaks as the bottom 89% is that fair of
course then it's totally absurd so we'll
cut back on education we'll cut back on
Medicaid we'll cut back on the needs of
our veterans we'll cut back on the needs
of people who are in trouble in order to
give huge tax breaks to the rich but is
that an accident no that's the way the
system works and what I try to do along
with many other members of Congress
including your very excellent
congresswoman Eleanor Holmes Norton who
does an excellent job is to bring
working people the middle class together
to stand up and fight against big-money
and that is a tough tough fight so
that's a brief synopsis of how I got to
where I am and a little bit of what I am
doing but this is your program not mine
so I'm happy to take any questions or
thoughts that you may have and please
don't be shy okay was the first question
I do okay you said that you support the
base that the rights of the
working-class why do you believe that
the United States so violently tries to
overthrow other forms of government such
as socialist governments such as what
happened in Chile in 1973 and in Cuba
why is the United States responding such
moneyed interests excellent quite
everyone hear the question okay if you
look and not enough people do and that
gets me into a whole other issue which
is the media which I want to talk about
because I'm very concerned about the
media today and the degree to which a
few corporations control what we see
here and read but if you check American
history you know sometimes the president
will tell you while we are always
defenders of freedom we believe in
freedom but if you check history what
you will find is that in many years
especially in Latin America which way
back from when President Monroe
developed his Monroe Doctrine we have
the right to own Latin America and we
will tell any government that what we
want to happen that's the simple truth
so throughout our history we have
overthrown many many governments we
didn't like their form of government in
the case of Chile in 1973 what you had
is an election in which a guy named
Salvador Allende won the election
problem is Nixon and his friends didn't
like of why bigger Salvin yah and
they've fought for the poor people and
the working people of that country he
belong I believe that the resources of
Chile their copper mines and so forth
should belong to the people he won a
free election
no one denied that for a second it was a
tough election in win by much but he won
a free election there was another
election his party got more support he
was overthrown by the CIA and corporate
interest because corporate interests
preferred of course that the United
States companies dominate that country
and a lot of what politics is about
going way way back to the 19th century
England France is the domination of
colonies so that big companies in a
given country can take the resources of
those countries for their own use so I
think that's what happened and it was a
very unfortunate day in American history
again day one in a democratic election
was popular was overthrown and
eventually killed and it is place a guy
named General Pinochet took place ran
that country with an iron fist killed
many many people but it was okay he was
a good guy why because he was a friend
of corporate America other questions yes
sir you're not a Democrat you're not a
Republican so what kind of
constituencies do you have that keep
your office any questions what groups
contribute money to your good
excellent question you see I think that
my politics in Vermont and in fact
throughout the country represents the
vast majority of the people okay so this
is the coalition that we put together we
stand up for senior citizens in my state
and I've been a leader in the United
States Congress in trying to lower the
cost of prescription drugs now you talk
to some of your grandparents about
whether they can afford the prescription
drugs they need it is an outrage that we
have people who die in this country who
get sick because they can't pay the
prices that the drug companies want them
to pay and in our country we pay by far
the highest prices in the world
so I say with seniors and we meet with
seniors a whole lot we're gonna fight to
lower your prescription drugs we're
gonna fight for a strong prescription
drug benefit under Medicare and in fact
we're gonna fight for a national health
care program now how many of you guys
know which major country in the world
the only one that does not guarantee
health care to all of their people let
me see how smart you are what is the
country in the world that does not
guarantee health care to all of their
people it's the United States of America
okay so we talked to the seniors we
talked to workers I am on the picket
line very often with workers were
fighting to create a union or to defend
their rights to get a decent standard of
living and I've always had the support
and get funding now I don't take in
terms of funding which is a good
question of where do I get my money do I
run for free new I have to take on the
whole Republican National Committee and
I have a lot of money if they want to
run against me so we get some of our
money from unions we're very strong on
the environment I have a 100% voting
record on the environment so we got help
from environmental groups get help from
senior groups I think it's an outrage
that in our country we have the highest
rate of childhood poverty of any nation
and our so we get help from groups who
are concerned about kids but most of my
funds do not come from PACs most of my
funds interestingly enough and we I
think are unique or maybe not maybe one
or two other people in the Congress most
of my funding comes from small
individual contributions I do not take
and never have taken in
we'll take one penny from any
corporation because I don't represent
their interest but all over America
people send me and in the state of
Vermont we receive you know whole lots
of funding from people said Bernie I can
afford a $20 check or a $30 check or a
$50 check location a couple of hundred
dollar checks so almost uniquely in the
Congress my money comes from small
contributions averaging about thirty
three dollars a piece or from huge
numbers of people lots of people ten
fifteen thousand people contributing 30
bucks a piece you got four hundred and
fifty thousand dollars and then you get
some money from unions and other other
groups and that's how I put together my
funds but the coalition I talk about
coalition politics and that's what we
have done in the Congress as well with
the Progressive Caucus is about we have
members of the Black Caucus we have
members of the Hispanic Caucus we have
members of the Women's Caucus we have
people from big cities we have people
like myself from rural America but our
goal is that people come together not be
divided by race by geographical district
district but coming together on basic
economics saying let's make this great
country work for everybody or not just
the very wealthy but answer your
question okay yes sir Oh my name is
Michael and my ideas stem off of your
idea of universal health care coverage
in our country it costs people an arm
and a leg just to get sufficient health
care and Senator Kerry has been that
proposing his idea of what it should be
like would you describe yourself as a
supporter of his plan or which you
provide modifications or do you
altogether have your own plan as to how
our country can provide universal health
care coverage okay Michael excellent
question and you're raising a question
at least in my state and I'm sure in
every other state in this country is way
up there on the top so let's just deal
with a couple effects and I'm glad you
as I mentioned the moment ago and as you
understand disgracefully the United
States is the only country in the
industrialized world of wealthy nations
that does not guarantee health care to
all people now if tomorrow somebody
would have say that in the city of
Washington or in the state of Maryland
or in the state of Virginia or in the
state of Vermont you can't go to school
unless your family has $50,000 a year
people said well that's crazy everybody
has a right to an education but do you
know way back when that wasn't always
the case
public education came because people
thought they said our kids are as good
as the wealthy kids and they deserve an
education and an equal opportunity other
countries have made that assumption
correctly about health care all right
everybody can get sick everybody can get
hit by a car everybody can come down
with a terrible disease now why should
it be in this country
that if somebody has a lot of money they
can go to the best hospitals the best
doctors in the country but if you're a
working class person and you work in a
place where they don't provide health
care or minimal health care
you're gonna go bankrupt paying for that
and you're clearly not going to despite
when anyone tells you if you think the
middle class a working class gets the
same type of health care as the rich
you're fooling yourself
all right so most countries in the world
have come up with different formulations
all right but what you should know I
spoke last it was very funny thing I've
talked to kids from England and the
college kids and I said well tell me
show me your healthcare card and they
all laughed in England everybody has
health care they're gonna have a cod go
to the doctor of your choice and so
forth and so on here's the facts about
health care number one forty-one million
Americans have no health care health
insurance on top of that there are many
many more
underinsured Michael what do I mean by
underinsured you know what I mean by
that you wouldn't be able to raise
sufficient funds to get the health care
you need to provide for your illness
right you may have some health care
coverage to cover you if you got hit by
a bus but you have a large deductible
and you know you're sick but you're not
gonna go to the doctor's you can't come
up with a hundred bucks right okay
meanwhile we spend twice as much per
person here's the first point to make
compared to all the other systems in the
world which provide health care to all
of their people we spend twice as much
per person as any other country now why
is that because to a large degree our
system is not geared to provide the best
quality health care to all of the people
it is geared primarily for what what is
what is a kid for what are the interns
companies therefore what does the drug
companies therefore but but profit so
here you have a situation let's just
deal with the drug companies year after
year the drug companies are the most
profitable industry in America and yet
they charge the American people the
highest prices in the world they pay
their CEOs in some cases tens of
millions of dollars a year but they
contribute huge amounts of money to
campaigns campaign contributions
advertising lot they have 600 lobbyists
on Capitol Hill alone very very powerful
when you see the president do a
fundraiser what mark my words the drug
companies will not be far away okay so
the first thing we have to do is create
a health care system which is not based
on profit and greed but I'm providing
good quality health care for all people
I believe in what is called a
single-payer system I don't know if
you're familiar with that concept but
basically what it says is you don't need
private insurance companies that what we
should have and I believe it should be
administered at the statewide level
because I think it would be more
efficient to do that rather than in
Washington but essentially everybody has
one cog you're in one publicly funded
insurance company and it provides
freedom of choice and quality care to
every American we can do it study after
study has shown that you can do that
without spending any more money than
we're currently spending and kind of
providing health care to all people you
take the profit motive out of it you
take the bureaucracy out of it you have
one insurance company here's another
here's another there's a huge amount of
bureaucracy which we waste money and we
want to put money into health care and a
simple system publicly funded can do
that ok other questions yes please
hi um how do you feel about the
University of Michigan undergraduate in
Law School cases on affirmative action I
believe in affirmative action I believe
in affirmative action and I think given
the history of our country affirmative
action not only for minorities but for
women is appropriate so that's the
simple answer other questions yes sir
you said that to the that you represent
the views of a majority of Americans
what why do you think that that the
Republican Party now controls the entire
Congress and and the white house is the
liberal coalition sort of
let me tell you so I'm not a liberal I'm
a progressive and there's a difference
now kind of liberal but I am more of
progressive than I am a liberal and I
want to talk about that but let's talk
about why the Republicans are doing so
well because that's an important
question now why would a party be doing
well when their can providing hundreds
of billions of dollars to the wealthiest
1% in tax breaks well we can understand
that the richest 1% would be very
delighted with them right but what about
the other 99% why do they get some of
those votes well there are a couple of
reasons let me go to an issue that I'm
now spending a great deal of time on I
want you to think and think hard about
okay it is the media we're on c-span let
me congratulate c-span for doing what I
consider to be an excellent job allowing
people with different points of view to
be heard all over America but c-span is
only one small part of the whole media
scheme scheme of things who owns NBC's
anybody in this room know who owns NBC
no you see you should be knowing these
things and you should be thinking about
this who owns and B sixties NBC just a
little old independent companies out
there trying to get all the news and
presenting all points of view NBC is
owned by General Electric one of the
largest corporations in America what
might be the conflicts of interest
between a company like General Electric
and and NBC the this the outlet that it
owns the network that our knowns is
there a conflict of interest do you
think that NBC will be General Electric
really wants to give you all points of
view what do you all think
what's their vice they think gonna stand
up do you think they are gonna focus on
the needs of working people let me give
you an example
General Electric like many other large
corporations over the last 20 years has
laid off large numbers of American
workers how manufacturing base in
America is disintegrating you all know
what I'm talking about when I talk about
that it's not talked about very much you
don't see that on television what do I
mean about that many of our parents
worked in factories I know it's not a
sexy job but they were able to make a
decent amount of money where are those
jobs gone overseas the what countries
all right why do companies like General
Electric run to China how much does a
worker in China make well give me they
make something no no give me an idea I
want you to study these things and by
the way before I go further and forget
we have a website which is a good
website we update it every day it's
called Bernie dot house gov Bernie dot
house.gov well you can get it through
the Congressional website process under
Vermont okay and we talked about these
issues but here I'm just gonna give you
an example about General Electric
General Electric the very large
corporation which has laid off my guess
is hundreds of thousands of American
workers at least tens of thousands of
years rather than paying somebody in the
United States fifteen or twenty bucks an
hour a living wage they prefer to throw
that person out on the street and go to
China in China they pay people thirty
cents an hour forty cents an hour they
don't have to worry about unions because
of anyone trots will form a union in
China they get thrown in jail I don't
have to worry too much about
environmental regulations because the
Chinese government wants to attract
industry doesn't have too much in the
way of environmental regulations it's a
great place to do business now do you
think that NBC will be talking about
that issue too much no I don't think
that they will okay General Electric
throughout its history has been
anti-union
they don't like unions you think they're
gonna be talking about how you can form
a union or the fact that workers in
unions make 25 percent more than
non-union workers do you guys no no I
don't
so General Electric owns a lot of
financial services vestment companies
and so forth
are they going to talk about the power
of estimate companies and how some of
them can screw consumers I don't think
so
and it's true for all the other
companies there's a guy named Rupert
Murdoch how many ever heard of Rupert
Murdoch who is Rupert Murdoch well he
owns a lot more than Fox Rupert Murdoch
is a gentleman from Australia whose
father owned meteor in Australia and he
took that and expanded in Australia
expanded in England expanded in Eastern
Europe is now in China and owns in this
country the New York Post and Fox
television he is an extreme right-wing
billionaire and when you watch Fox
television you should not have any
illusions that you're watching an
independent television network what
you're watching is an adjunct of the
Republican Party every one of their
hosts are extreme right-wing and that is
true for other cable stations as well
very serious problem and one of the
issues that I am working on is that in a
time in America we have a handful of
corporations like General Electric
Viacom huge corporation owning CBS
Disney huge corporation owning ABC AOL
Time Warner huge corporation owning CNM
Rupert Murdoch's News Corporation owning
Fox New York Post other media outlets
all over the world as bad as that
situation is who owns the Washington
Times yeah what about that guy did is he
believe in democracy but you should
study it it is important to understand
who owns what Washington Post is owned
by a big corporation are they focusing
on the needs of ordinary people do they
deal with the real issues give you one
example of all of the economic issues
facing our country today I'm going to
throw out a very simple one and I want
you to think about because you guys are
the future of this country I want you to
understand it in the last thirty years
we have obscene an explosion of
Technology right when I was your age
they didn't have computers they didn't
have emails they didn't have
taxes I was mayor Burling a big
revolution we got a fax machine in City
Hall okay I you're laughing at the cat's
ancient history
it's not ancient history twenty years
ago now in all you have robotics you
have factories that are much more
productive the point being that every
worker in America is much more
productive with all of that technology
correct would you assume that given the
explosion of that technology and all of
the skills that American workers now
have you would assume that the average
American worker is now working fewer
hours making more money that your
parents are saying wow man 30 years ago
they used to have to work 40 50 hours a
week isn't it great we can work twenty
five hours of weakness we have all of
that technology and we have really solid
middle-class incomes no problem sending
you guys to college health care is not a
problem taking care of Grandma is not
the reality
so the $64 question is what happened in
a thirty year period with all of the
technology and the reality is that the
average American today not the rich but
the average American is working longer
hours for low wages in my state it is
not uncommon we're a rural state we're
on the went out of poor state but we're
in the lower end of things it is not
uncommon at all to speak to workers who
do not work one job do not work two jobs
but occasionally work three jobs
how did that happen with all of that
technology why is that our standard of
living for the average middle-class
person going up but while the middle
class is disappearing in many ways
shrinking what's happening to the people
on top they are getting rich up by the
barrel full in the last 20 years the
people on top have made out like bandits
and now of course they want more in the
way of tax breaks how often do you see
that issue discussed on television oh my
god they must have missed that issue but
the latest scandal what about that
Peterson case you see a little bit about
that every no what about OJ Simpson you
heard about that every night but you see
what the media will do is not deal to a
large degree with the issues facing the
middle class and explain okay if the
middle class
is shrinking if we have the highest rate
of childhood poverty in the
industrialized world if the rich have
done phenomenally richer we got a
problem
and now we may disagree as to how we
solve that problem we got to lay it on
the table so that we can begin what kind
of society we want Michael here raised
the question about health care you
believe in health care for all people
Michael how many of you believe in
health care for all people raise your
hands well you know what so do the
people in Vermont so do the people all
over America not the President of the
United States not to Congress okay why
aren't we discussing that reality about
how we can have a health care system
that shouldn't cost us any more than the
current health care system and it gonna
be on NBC very often I can tell you that
we won't talk about that every scandal
in the world you'll talk about every
crime in the world one of you guys
throws a brick through a window you'll
make it on the front pages but if you
sit down and you do your work and you're
thoughtful about things you may never
make it at all workers do not get they
have views their needs express them the
result is of that is that a lot of good
people who work day and night they say
hey must be something wrong with me I'm
working 50 60 hours a week and no one's
talking about my needs I'm not gonna
vote it's all crap and that's part of
the system of what they want so they
don't want to be honest with you
the people who own America do not want
you voting they do not want you
participating in the political system
they'd rather have a system in which the
rich contribute huge amounts of money to
the Republican Party maybe to the
Democratic Party they'll make decisions
for those people but not for you that's
why you have got to turn that around but
my point about the media is and you can
do this increasingly with the internet
read alternative sources read magazines
that are not necessarily mainstream
magazines know who owns the media that
you're reading read Fox watch Fox
understand this comes from an extreme
right-wing perspective then read other
magazines that give you and other
outlets that give you different points
of view but then when you ask me that
question
that's one of the reasons I think the
media does a terrible job in addressing
and talking about the needs of the
middle-class I'll give you another
answer you should ask the good question
question is has a Republican Party do so
good and now I'm going to tell you
something the very few people in
Congress would tell you if you are the
Republican leadership
and this is what your goals are you also
to give huge tax breaks the very richest
people in this country your goals are
ultimately to privatize Social Security
so that Wall Street can make money from
that privatize Medicare so the insurance
companies can make more money privatize
education their way with public schools
if those are your goals and you said
that for the American people you think
you get a lot of it lower there are many
members of the Congress today
Republicans who not only will not raise
the minimum wage which is 515 and now
you know what they will tell you
honestly they believe in abolishing the
minimum wage did you know that check it
out telling you the truth so that if
Americans could work for 3 bucks an hour
or 2 bucks an hour not a problem now if
you had an agenda like that and you went
before the American people tax breaks
for the rich destruction of Medicare
destruction of Social Security as we
know it lowering the minimum wage or
abolishing it how many votes do you
think you'd get not a whole lot
maybe the richest 1% would vote for you
that's not a lot of votes so what do I
do
it's got a problem you package it how do
you package it and here's I want you to
pay attention to me yes this is bad
stuff I don't mind the baiting people
who say I was on a Hannity show Sean how
many Oh yesterday and and Hannity
stream right wing guy he thinks we
should he loves these tax breaks for the
rich and so forth so we had a little bit
of a discussion about that actually was
a loud discussion where what I don't
mind people who upfront about that okay
give the rich more tax breaks but that
doesn't win you elections so this is
what you do what you do is divide people
up when you ask your question how do I
get elected I said I try to bring people
together we fight for women's rights
we support the rights of minorities we
support the rights of workers we bring
the majority of people to go and
occasionally honest people will have
differences of opinion in this room
little differences opinion but everybody
in this room is an agreement that
everybody should have health care right
question number two should we increase
funding for education or should we lower
funding for education raise you an do
you think we should increase funding for
education okay you're on the side of the
vast majority of Americans okay so on
those issues we
people together now what do the
Republicans try to do and they use it in
what we call you know kind of language
that they don't not upfront about what
do we do we divide people up by races
permit of action becomes one issue all
them black people are getting the jobs
that we white people used to have split
people working-class white against black
instead of working together to create
decent jobs through all those uppity
women now they want the right to choose
will split people on the abortion issue
will split people up on the gun issue
will split people up on religious issues
you follow what I'm saying so you split
people up and then they end up if you're
a middle class person voting against
your own interests and the rich go
laughing all the way to the bank okay
and they very often play white workers
off against everybody else and we try to
bring people together to say look we're
all in this boat together with you're
black or white whether you're Hispanic
whether you're Muslim whatever you may
be everybody needs health care how do we
create a healthcare system that works
for all people not divide people up
everybody knows that the kids young
people do not make it into the middle
class unless they have a decent college
education so how do we make college
education accessible to all people not
an expensive proposition a tiny tiny
fraction of the president's tax breaks
for the rich if we put into financial
aid would make sure that every young
person in this country could go to
college without going deeply into debt
you know what the vast majority of the
people support us but in order to do
that we got to bring everybody together
and many of these not all and I'm not
here to disparage all Republicans very
decent people happen to be conservative
I respect that but some people who I
don't respect will play off women
against men black against white oh the
gay issue very very big issue okay
straight against gay right well supposed
to hate gay people so we split that
group up and then the argument some of
us are not patriotic we had concerns
about the war in Iraq I voted against
giving the president authority to the
war in Iraq well that makes us
unpatriotic we hate America divide those
things up and that's how they succeed
and they succeed with the help of the
media because the media will not talk
about how in a sense the
common problems that Americans face and
how we bring people together and that's
what I believe I believe that on issues
like everybody in this room thinks I
think that instead of giving tax breaks
to the rich we should increase federal
aid to education anyone disagree with
that
well you know what most Americans agree
with all of you think that every
American should be entitled to health
care I suspect most of you think we
should not have a trade policy which
allows corporations and throw American
workers out on the street and run to
China most Americans agree with that and
how a job is to bring people together on
common interest and some of these
extreme right-wing people you watch the
issues that they talk about affirmative
action they used to divide the issue of
abortion they use to divide the issue of
guns they used to divide and our job is
to say let's focus on basic economic
issues how do we expand the middle class
this is a great country why is it the
average American is working longer hours
for low wages than 30 years ago let's
talk about that okay okay that was a
long answer to a good question I
apologize had gone on too long
other questions yes let me get to you
did you ask the first one yet no you
didn't she did okay yes I just wanted to
know how you feel about school vouchers
and do you feel that they benefit public
schools how do I feel about school
vouchers and how do you do do you feel
that they benefit public schools now
they certainly don't benefit public
schools ultimately this is an effort to
destroy public education what public
education is about is for a start saying
that we're going to provide the best
quality that we can every young person
in America are we doing a particularly
good job no we could do a lot better job
no question about it we should make our
public schools the best schools in the
entire world
we should make you study harder okay we
should be paying teachers the kind of
salaries they deserve for doing the
important work that they do do you know
and an issue that I've been involved in
before I'm gonna answer your questions
an excellent question but before you
guys got to school
some of you especially if you've come
from working families you went to
childcare I don't any of you guys got a
child care when you're little or you
have brothers and sisters in child care
do you know the child care workers in
many instances are paid less than
McDonald's workers and here they are
dealing with the formative years of a
child's life both emotionally and
intellectually we're paying child care
workers six or seven dollars an hour no
benefit huge turnover all right this has
to do with national priorities to my
mind if we are serious about loving our
country then the most precious resource
that we have is our children we should
not have the highest rate of poverty in
the industrialized world we should not
be underfunding education do you know
that in America and I you'll forgive me
for my ignorance yes you'll tell me the
answer this I don't know what's going on
in Washington DC right now but I do know
that in many parts of America you know
what's happening we're not bringing in
more teachers what are we doing because
of the crisis we are firing teachers we
are lowering the number of hours the
kids go to school but we have money for
tax breaks for the rich and corporate
welfare so to answer your question what
vouchers are about what public education
was about is that education for
democracy we bring everybody in the
community together summit richest on the
poor summer black summer white and we
learn how to live together how to
discuss things together how to love each
other as American citizens respect each
other and we pride ourselves on what we
learned well some right-wing Republicans
don't like anything that is public they
believe in private private party so what
they want to do is take money out of
public education and say we're gonna
start a private school and when you
start a private school some private
schools are great not against private
schools in America today most of the
kids who go to private schools come from
upper income families pay their teachers
schools are very very good Olson it's
the breeding ground for the you know
very very wealthy now what they want to
do if you start a private school what we
will say in the private skills okay
we're gonna start a private school and
unless you have a following admission
level unless you have exam
you can pass exams of this level unless
you're really good kid in school you're
not gonna get into that room you're not
gonna get into our private school well
maybe you have a disability you're not
gonna get in to that school so we're
gonna take the cream of the crop now
that may be a very good school and it's
cost money to have this what happens to
the rest of the kids who may not have
done so good on an exam when they were 7
years of age well we don't have quite
that much we're gonna dump them into
that school over there yeah it'll be 40
or 50 kids in a class but we got that
good school over there so I believe that
we adequately fund education in this
country which we're not doing what we
have done with education in America is
leave it to the cities and towns in my
state small rural state education is
primarily funded through the property
taxes which is a regressive property tax
and our last statewide elections 42
towns said they could not vote to
increase property taxes meanwhile
federal aid to education whether it's
special education or whatever is minimal
so to answer your questions no I do not
believe in vouchers I believe their
ultimate goal is to destroy public
education to have a segregated
educational system not primarily on race
but on class and that is wrong we have
gotten if we are serious about the
future of this country then we're
serious about education you fund it
respect your teachers we should have the
best people in America going into
teaching and they should be paid
commensurate with their responsibility
which is important people who educate
you play a very important role we've got
to respect them ok other questions yes
you're saying that the majority of
Americans share your views on issues
like health care and I'd like to believe
that's true what do you think needs to
be done to get the majority viewpoint
expressed in places like Congress and
the Supreme Court in the White House
well you need a political revolution
other than that it's not difficult that
was a joke guys the issue is that money
has so much power in this country ok
this is the power of money money owns
the media so they will tell you you know
basically they will focus on issues that
they want to focus on and ignore
important
issues like the healthcare crisis and
need for national health care system
money determines who gets elected to the
Congress the President as I understand
it will be spending 200 million dollars
on radio and television ads formerly TV
for his primary election to become the
Republican candidate for president guess
what
President does not have any opponents
200 million bucks what does that money
come from
will come from the wealthiest people in
this country so the what's the antidote
to that which is pretty tough stuff the
antidote is real campaign finance reform
that says to the president or anybody
else or any candidate for Congress you
know you can't take out we have members
in the Senate
my guess is could be wrong about this I
don't think I am about one third of the
United States Senate is millionaires do
you think about that one third of the
people you know millionaires more and
more people are running for office who
are rich themselves so what they do is
they take out their checkbook and they
write themselves a check for 50 million
dollars and they're off and running and
they got a good campaign do you think
that's what democracy should be about so
what you need is campaign finance reform
which basically says in a democracy I
don't have the right to outspend this
guy by 20 to 1 because I'm rich there'll
be a maximum amount that can be spent so
campaign finance reform is very
important opening up the media and again
c-span I think does a good job but
demanding that media starts is not just
owned by large corporations and by the
way if the president's deregulation
media effort is successful the FCC will
allow fewer corporations to control the
media
you'll be seeing cities in America will
they'll be one company that owns
television radio and newspapers so
you've got to democratize the media and
allow different points of view
ultimately to answer your question we
will not be successful if we have turn
of voter turnouts of 40 percent and if
20 percent of the young people vote you
guys are the future and you have got to
participate in the political process
when the majority get moving if we have
70 or 80 percent voter turnout our side
wins if it's a 40 percent voter turnout
their side wins
and the last point again is I think
coalition politics you bring people
together around common interests but it
means understanding that politics is
important and all of you you don't have
the luxury in my view of saying oh I
don't want to get involved in politics
on order if you don't want to get in
politics then your job that you're
hoping to get may go to China you may
not be able to go to college when you
get sick you may not have in health
insurance if you have little kids little
brothers or sisters
they now may not have good childcare so
if you don't want to get in volatile
that's fine but that's the reality
facing if you don't other questions yes
I want to know what was your position on
the welfare reform bill of 1996 I voted
against it I think Oh see that's a good
question getting back to his point and
that is how do the Republicans win well
what they do is they take the middle
class who is working now very very hard
people working 50 60 hours a week and
they say do you know where all your
money is going it's going to take care
of all those lazy people who just don't
want to work and a lot of people believe
that so do we need welfare reform sure
we do is welfare a good thing no but
what we want to do if you have a young
mother with two young kids you got to
take care of those you got to make sure
that the kid grows up with dignity
should we be able to try to educate that
mother get her a good job
absolutely to do that what are the
things you need you certainly need
education you need childcare you need
transportation what you don't want to do
and especially as the economy goes south
and gets worse you don't want to say to
somebody well we're taken away all of
your benefits for your kids there are no
jobs good luck to you
well how am I supposed to rely to health
care for my kids my business so welfare
reform is good depending on what it
means but what that was about was an
effort to really turn the middle-class
against the poor you with me okay so I
voted against that bill how do you feel
about being DC being sacked without
being represented well you say I'm in a
funny position how many folks are there
in DC anyone know
570,000 well in my state of Vermont
there are six hundred and twenty
thousand people so we're wanted with a
third smallest state in America we're a
little bit bigger than Washington DC we
have two United States senators and one
United States congressman who has full
voting rights what do you guys got well
you have one excellent congresswoman but
she doesn't have the right to vote in
many instances does that fail so I come
from a state which is just a hair bigger
than you guys so I can't say that that's
fair it's not fair so I believe that
Washington DC should be treated as
national national capitals are all over
the world and people here should have
full representation in the United States
Congress now let me ask you a question
which I suspect you know the answer why
don't you have that representation raise
your hand to tell me why let me know
somebody wasn't talk yet some of the
silent guides we have many silent ones
all right who wants to tell me why you
think Washington does not have that
representation yes why do
well it's it's been turned into a
partisan issue for many it is applause
for many Republican
what's the simple answer let's not beat
around the bush what's the answer what
what percentage of the vote the George
Bush get in Washington DC in the last
election but seven seven or eight
percent alright cool got ten or fifteen
times more than mr. Bush do you think
the Republicans are going to allow for
two United States Senator and one full
voting member of the House of
Representatives in a city which is
certainly never in the foreseeable
future gonna vote Republican period and
the discussion that's the issue and I
will go on for long speeches about oh no
no no no Dada but that's the reality
that's the simple reality everybody
knows that reality now if you wanted to
get two United States senators and one
full voting member you have to vote
Republican then you'll get it but so
long as the politics is what it is right
now because right now who controls the
United States Senate fifty forty nine
and one independent it is from the state
of Vermont by the way in the Senate for
the Republicans and if you had two
United States senators there who were
not Republican and this is a progressive
City so it's not only that it would not
be Republicans they would be at least
progressive Democrats maybe independence
closer to my point of view that is not
something that the moneyed interests
want to see in the nation's capital hi
my name is tanisha and I wanted to talk
a little bit about the youth I feel
naughty youth youth programs and
different things yes money has a lot of
power but I also feel that the public
voices have power too and I want someone
to point out different points about I
think that a lot of youth although we
don't come out in large numbers I think
a lot of youth in this school and in DC
are doing things about like just
different issues affirmative action and
we have a bam-bam meetings here
we also have different other things and
I also want to know what other programs
do you believe should be put into place
about youth and how can we I get to this
to talk to the Congress man how can we
make our voices be heard
okay in my state as I've indicated
despite a very busy schedule I have
tried to go to every high school in the
state because I think meetings like this
are terribly important and I think you
have the right your citizens of this
country and you'll be voting in a few
years but even if before that you have
the right to hear what members of
Congress believe and you have the right
to question them and say look these are
our concerns that's what democracy is
about so what I would do is write a
letter to your local leaders to the
people you want and bring them right
here into the school and many of them
will come I believe okay you have power
if you say look here's a letter signed
by 80 people please come and talk to us
about a B and C we're concerned about it
okay that's number one number two in
terms of youth issues in general the
first thing that I want to to say to you
is you are a very bright group of young
people but I'm sure you wouldn't be here
if you weren't and your hard workers but
we have got to fight for is to make sure
that every person in this room and every
young person in America wants to go to
college is able to go to the college of
his or her choice now if you get into
that college without worrying about the
financial implications right now kids
are getting out of college thirty forty
thousand dollars in debt you know that
and a lot of lower-income kids are
saying gee I don't know if I want to go
get thirty thousand forty thousand
dollars in debt because there may not be
a job then when I get out okay
that's absurd so I want young people all
over in America to say we got to work on
that issue immediately what we should be
doing is opening up schools 24 hours a
day if you want to be here to study at
10 o'clock in the evening you should be
able to have access to that in Vermont
we're now trying to get health care
facilities into schools dental care
doctors into schools to take care of the
special needs of young people but you
owe us at the main point that I want to
make on that question never forget this
don't let anyone beat you down you are
citizens of the United States of America
and you have a right to make
demands on the system you have a right
to say excuse me I want a decent job I
want health care I want good quality
education I'm as good as anybody else
even if my family is not that wealthy
and we're gonna fight for those rights
that's the best part of American history
in some ways we have come a long way in
some ways we haven't but if we stick
together we're not get divided up by
race by religion by geographical
district Orban rule whatever it may be
we can succeed in doing those things
okay so I I just want to conclude by
applauding you all for your interest in
politics in government this is your
country and you study the issues and you
fight for what you think is right okay
thank you all very much good morning
congressman and thank you thank you very
much friend welcome to school without
walls on behalf of our students our
faculty and certainly our parents I'd
like to welcome you and thank you for
what I'm sure knowing my children was a
very engaging conversation to say the
least and as a token of our appreciation
we'd like you to become a walls penguin
an honorary penguin thank you very much
raining outside this is doubly
appropriate perfect thank you well thank
you for doing the wonderful job and you
certainly have some great County yes
premier school Washington DC yes thank
you
yes
just so you all know the news this
morning was that christine Todd Whitman
who's supposed to be our speaker just
resigned from the stick
but on a brighter note one of the things
that we are doing a large ocean rich
students in these are seniors in there
right now we're doing a $25,000
scholarship competition that some
conjunction with the students will need
your project that we're doing as you go
to 40 schools over the past Friday